what are you doing I'm deconstructing my
sandwich Tick Tock said that I have to
eat the vegetables first to meet second
and then the bread if I want to manage
my blood sugars research suggests that
there are significant benefits to eating
your carbs less we're largely done in
folks with diabetes and the one that was
done with healthy participants had eight
subjects oh so it's all [ __ ] it's
actionable it just totally over
complicates things we do know that there
are benefits to dressing up naked carbs
by pairing them with a source of fiber
protein and healthy fats aka the hunger
crushing combo and if it makes sense in
the context of a specific meal to like
have your veggies first like a salad for
example then I think that there is some
benefit to that but stressing over
deconstructing your sandwich or
meticulously making sure that you're
eating a piece of broccoli or chicken
before a piece of pasta in a casserole
seems like it's missing the forest from
the trees